al estrechar manos nada más llegar de
washington by the end y yair lapid
recordaron como hace ocho años bromeaban
sobre lo que les hacía falta en estatura
y pelo blanco para ser presidente de
eeuu y primer ministro de israel aunque
en funciones en el caso de lápiz ha sido
él quien ha guiado a bailén por sus dos
primeras visitas simbólicas en cuanto a
identidad del estado hebreo la defensa y
el recuerdo del holocausto sobre lo
primero en el aeropuerto de tel aviv
israel mostró a byd en un prototipo
láser antiaéreo cuyo fin es derribar
misiles y drones en el aire sobre los
segundo by the end conversó en el museo
yad vashem de jerusalén con dos
sobrevivientes judías que emigraron a
eeuu tras la segunda guerra mundial y
desde ahí llamó a combatir el
antisemitismo un es una camaradería
estadounidense israelí que contrasta con
el sentir palestino de hecho en su
primera referencia al conflicto opacado
por irán arabia saudita y yemen by then
reiteró esa manida solución de dos
estados sin dar ninguna propuesta y
admitiendo que la ve poco factible a
corto plazo
de ese escepticismo palestino se debe a
que líderes como byd en quien no reniega
de la etiqueta sionista contribuyan de
alguna manera a profundizar la ocupación
israelí aunque su parada en territorios
palestinos será el viernes en ramala y
velen ese descontento ya se ha
ejemplificado en carteles colgados por
la ong betselem con la leyenda señor
presidente esto es apartheid en
referencia a las leyes y políticas de
desigualdad israel contra los palestinos
por mucho que el presidente se esfuerza
en no obviar el conflicto e incluirlo en
su agenda una de sus principales
misiones en este viaje es vincular a
israel con arabia saudita agudizando la
cooperación árabe israelí que a la vez
deja más aislados a los palestinos